muito obrigado é e agradeço a
oportunidade estar aqui no ted x unicamp
e você começar também dizendo boa tarde
a todos ea todos aqui presentes e que
também não nos ver e depois no vídeo é
bom já foi apresentado no meu nome é
também uma peça farelo ele falar um
pouquinho aqui com vocês a respeito da
criatividade na composição musical
contemporânea
eu sou compositora é só o pesquisador
lado siddiqui da unicamp e sou também
compositor é muitas vezes a música
realmente faz parte do dia a dia das
pessoas
dessa forma muitas pessoas me perguntam
ah sim o que o que eu faço com que eu
faço para compor uma música e muitas
vezes esses pensamentos com essas
perguntas vêm de embu idos e alguns
pensamentos tais como será que o
compositor é um gênio isolado em seu
mundo tal como a figura de apresentada
ou então será que o compositor tinha uma
mente iluminada
enfim algumas perguntas que normalmente
eu ouço por aí
e na verdade o que o meu ponto de vista
que na realidade não é bem isso acontece
o que eu acredito que na verdade uma
nova música uma nova criação musical é
um compositor
ela estabelece um diálogo com um por
exemplo outras manifestações do
pensamento tais como conceitos
filosóficos novas tecnologias ou então
outras artes tais como os textos
poéticos literários pinturas outras
músicas mesmo ou então ainda com
vivências passadas do compositor tais
como uma viagem que fizemos um lugar
conhecemos sonoridades que ouvimos
quando fomos atrás lugares
enfim na verdade esse quadro que se
apresenta aí ele não tem a intenção de
ser conclusiva
tá ele apenas um alguns exemplos eu
dividia em três porque eu vou mostrar
pra vocês então agora três exemplos
que se ligam mais fortemente cada um
deles a um desses três quadros que ali
estão
o primeiro exemplo era uma só pra gente
isso aqui é uma peça de silvio ferraz
silva ferraz
ele é compositor atualmente trabalhando
na usp universidade de são paulo mas já
foi também compositor professora da
unicamp e e o canto de verônica
tanto de verônica é pouco explicou por
que falam disso é o seguinte na
procissão do enterro que é algo que
acontece durante a semana santa
o canto de verônica é um dos ritos dessa
pressão porque ele é encantado por uma
mulher enquanto ela desenrola 11 tecido
no qual está estampado o rosto de jesus
no caso faz parte de um dos ritos
católicos seria a idéia de que essa
pessoa a verônica auxiliou jesus
enxugando o rosto dele com o pano quando
ele foi necessário é o que faz parte da
tradição toda forma a mostrar pra vocês
aqui um pequeno vídeo sobre um canto de
verônica que aconteceu nessa de prazos
em minas gerais
não é exatamente um ano mas só tem tv
exemplifica
[Música]
ae
o compositor silvio ferraz dêem no ano
de 1988 pôde presenciar o canto de
verônica realizado na cidade de prado de
minas gerais no qual ele foi feito pela
senhora na geladeira isso tocou
profundamente o compositor a ponto de 20
anos após esse contato em 2008 e ter
composto uma uma peça para violoncelo
solo orquestra de cordas percussão que
se chama itinerário da passagem
verônica na dilma nessa peça escrita
para orquestra de são brás do suaçuí e
também para o violoncelista fábio
presgrave ele trabalha a reestrutura de
sonoridades provenientes do da procissão
tais como os toques de sirene o arrastar
do da multi do arrastar dos pés a
multidão toque de matracas voz moranis
etc
vou tocar aqui pra vocês então um
trechinho da recriação feita por silvio
ferraz para o canto da verônica
tal como o que acabamos eu vivo
[Música]
nosso próximo exemplo vem do compositor
e professora da unicamp
jônatas manzolli é na sua obra
descobertas
cada um dos quatro atos que trabalhar
sobre o compositor liga se com uma das
etapas de da criatividade trabalhados
pelo autor gravar aulas que são fundação
germinação e iluminação e reflexão
além desse ligação com o autor
o interessante na obra de jonas manzoli
é que o uso de meios diversos para a sua
especialidade sonora tais como
distribuição especializada da cast do
couro
a interação com outras artes tais como a
dança o vídeo ou então ainda a interação
com novas tecnologias como aplicativos e
dispositivos móveis
nós vamos o mostrar um trecho aqui da
obra descoberto um dos meus olhos
já são três curtos trechos depois de
comer um pouquinho sobre eles
[Música]
é ela
o que foi possível perceber no primeiro
momento a participação do balé junto com
a orquestra um segundo momento em que os
coralistas com seus dispositivos móveis
influencia na que está sendo tocado
especializado nas caixas acústicas
distribuídas no palco e um terceiro
momento dá pra perceber claramente tanto
assim a especialização da orquestra e da
percussão quanto também a interação com
o vídeo
o terceiro e último exemplo e mostrar
pra vocês é de uma peça que o mesmo
concurso
no final do ano 2015
eu sofri um grave acidente
automobilístico e isso obviamente foi
bastante triste né foi um susto muito
grande para mim para minha família e ao
mesmo tempo eu havia recebido encomenda
para a criação de uma nova composição
por parte da ans ambos mobile que é um
grupo curitibano de música contemporânea
dedicada a execução da música
contemporânea
o processo então de criação dessa nova
peça eu me deparei com o poema tumulto e
cecília meireles o qual por sua beleza e
seus caráteres tristes e melancólicos
eu senti que havia uma ressonância
grande com aquilo que eu queria
expressar minha nova peça
então vou tocar para vocês aqui um
trechinho da estréia da peça choro vão
da água entre si
aliás até o nome da peça é um dos versos
do poema de cecília meireles e nós
iremos ouvir o a declamação do poema
pelo regente do grupo márcio e um final
um trecho mais para o final da peça em
que pra mim é o trecho mais melancólico
da música
helewa tse julgou o how i e ii
[Música]
o
então para concluir muito longe daquela
idéia de que o compositor talvez fosse
um gênio isoladamente iluminada algo do
tipo que não faz muito sentido
o que eu defendo é que na verdade é que
uma possível maneira de pensar a
criatividade na composição musical
também outras formas de pensamento né
mas enfim mais sobre a música é por meio
do diálogo gizmo no qual uma criação é
percy passada porém num pronunciado
diversos por outras vozes inacabadas
mosaicos citações remissão a outros
dizeres ele está efetivamente já
produzidos que a antecederam lhe deram
origem e fazem parte da memória social
afetiva de pesquisa e/ou de vivência do
compositor
muito obrigado pela atenção e aí pra
mostrar pra vocês
[Aplausos]